on va
commencer avec la folie du jour en
Italie ce weekend à Lyon s'est échappé
d'un cirque et a semé la terreur dans
les rues
[Musique]
regardezada
[Applaudissements]
im devant la
mais je peux tei l'image de Leon le
porche le je peux te dire que tuant chez
toi il y aura pas de
squ tu es plutôt tranquille qu'il est
chez
luio le
li mais il est incroable frérot
d'habitude dans C r tu sais as toujours
des petitsch tu sais et compagnie ils
ont vu la bête onite onentend
personneent
personne c'est
horrible non mais c'est vrai que c'est
un truc de fou parce qu'il marche
tranquille non mais e tu imagines tu
imagines tu es tranquille tu es en train
de char tu es au téléphone frère un
frère mais c'est quoi qu'est-ce tu mais
j'aais bien savoir ta réaction parce que
je vous l'ai déjà dit si vous faites
courser par un chien faut monter sur une
voiture ça m'est déjà arrivé monter sur
une voiture un lion c'est un peu relou
euh un peu relou le lion je me suis
jamais fait attaquer par un liyon à part
la barre chocolatée mais
franchement c'est pas en plus que le
liyon est mon animal préféré moi après
le vrai scandale le vrai scandale c'est
qu'il y a encore des lions RA galdine on
a pas envie d'être chiant à
19h47 merci t'inquiète pas on a bien le
temps dans l'autre partie de l'émission
donc c'est bon tu reviendras tout à
l'heure merci moi j'ai eu ça avec un
tigre à France 2 il a eu un tigre qui a
été tué sous mes sous mes fenêtres à
France 2 sous les fenêtres de
mon tig il y a un cirque en fait qui est
encore là en face de France Télévision
depuis des années et il venait d'arriver
ce cirque et moi je partais j'avais mon
mteau et puis je voyais les gens
d'envoyer spécial qui étaient un peu
excités et tout ça en fait un
échaé c'était un fau mais et et et ce
que ce qui est dingue c'est qu'ils ont
arrêté évidemment le le tramo et
j'imagine le message que les gens ont
entendu nous nous sommes obligés
d'arrêter de tram parce qu'il y a un
tigre sur les VO
chiant j'avoue que ce côté n'est pas ouf
franchement autant ce côté ça se passe
bien là ce côté c'est pas ouf c'est
catastrophique c'est catastrophique a dû
rester non mais c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon on a compris c'est bon en fait
en fait sa quoi tu quoi fais une pause
tuenlèves ton enquer tu ver
ohz un petit
ver ver tu restes un peu comme ça 5 10
minutes t'inquiète pas comment comment
tu as loupé la meilleure vanne de
Raymond qui a dit enlève ton stérilet et
ton
stérrident mais Raymon ron ron Raymon tu
vas passer de l'autre côté je te dis tu
vas passer de l'autre côté ah la Cour de
cassation a
tranché l'insolence envers son patron
n'est pas un motif de licenciements bne
n Cour de
cassation la Cour de cassation je
va
regardez insolence même envers son
patron n'est pas un motif valable de
licenciement les seules limites à la
liberté d'expression au travail sont la
diffamation ou l'insulte en fait la Cour
de cassation s'est prononcée sur le cas
d'un salariier qui contestait son
licenciement il avait lourdement insisté
auprès de son patron pour obtenir des
congés en dehors des périodes prévues
par l'entreprise avec une certaine
insolence he il a obtenu gain de cause
et ensuite il a écrit à son patron je
considère que l'incident est clos en
clair un salarié qui n'hésite pas à
tenir tête et même à narguer son patron
pour obtenir gain de cause et bien la
justice lui a donné raison ce n'est pas
un motif de licenciement
ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle incroable si c'est légal ça
veut dire qu'on peut être un sol avec
vous très très bonne nouvelle alors je
t'explique voilà
l'égalité demain tu es pas là demain pas
là je dis alors moi ça cette décision
mais je vous le dis elle elle ne tient
pas
ici c'est la cour de
casse de Patricia C je texque vous
pouvez rieness là je vous dis là je vous
dis un gros
[Applaudissements]
connard c'était la dernière
deé vous pouvez pas remettre en cause la
Cour de cassation vas faire toi la Cour
de cassation et moi on
[Applaudissements]
t'emmerde
s tu verras C tu seras pas là tu menaces
pas G comme
ça mais g tu seras pas là demain
libertéexpression tu veras demain tu
seras pas là tu verras alors je peux
vous dire je peux avoir des
T tu verras demain tu seras chez toi et
tu verras bien tu verras quand Fatou va
te dire tu commences à me
gonferour tu verras quand tu vias me
supplier par contre là déjà c'est
salaire divisé par de oh mais çaut dire
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on a le
droit vous de vous harceler non mais les
gars les gars allez-y allez en cours de
Cass le temps que vous alliez en cours
de cassass et vous fassiez les procès je
vais faire des recours vous savez quoi
je vous le dis on a le droit decer on a
dro on a le droit de te faire chier tu
peux rien faire ou parce qu'à un moment
je suis plus le patron je vais aller
chez vous je vais vous
défer 21h1 vont partir tu vas voir je
vais aller chez lui je lui péter le nez
tu
vois il y aura pas de patron là tu VO
allez non non non t'inquiète pas e dans
la dans la
bienveillance il sera évidemment la
demain bien s non il sera pas là il sera
pas là demain
pourol rigole pas tu seras pas là non
plus les chées il a un peu parlé fort
aussi non ça va il il a rien dit de mal
il a voulu il a voulu y aller et après
il
s je fais comme l'employé de cette
affaire je considère que l'incident est
clos
tu seras pas là
demain tu seras pas là demain TR sont pr
là demain les chériis info dans ce qu'il
ne fallait pas louper Benjamin Castaldi
travaille arrête je l'embrasse Benjamin
j'ai au
téléphone
non non parce que je dis ça Benjamin
Castali travaille avec Angela Lorente
sur une série à propos de télééalité
voilà non mais il y a pas besoin de
mettre le truc voilà donc c'est Benjamin
il travaille là-dessus donc je suis
content pour lui et bien sûr je serai là
pour l'ider s'il en a besoin ben
toujours sa pièce est géniale oui mais
qui travaille un peu ce serait bien mais
j'adore Benjamin je vais aller le voir
d'ailleurs prochaine j'is le voir
semaine prochaine et pour l'instant je
l'embrasse et bravo à lui et s'il veut
venir me voir avec grand plaisir les
chir est-ce que vous avez vu cette
histoire de ce de ce détenu qui a gagné
800000 € lors d'un tournoi de poker en
ligne depuis sa cellule incroyable
histoire
regardez regardez on l'a
pas alors alors l'histoire est folle
Gilles au moin que tu serves quelque
chose alors l'histoire est incroyable
parce que il a été d'abord condamné et
puis il a gagné au poker et quand il est
sorti son ex-comagne a porté plainte
contre lui en l'accusant de viol mais
lui dit que ce n'est pas vrai qu'en fait
elle a voulu lui prendre la somme qu'il
avait gagné elle a voulu qu'il verse une
pension alimentaire extraordinaire qui
lui paye aussi une opération de
chirurgie esthétique donc pour le moment
on en est là c'est paroles contre parole
Cyril il est pas sûr que le fait d'avoir
gagné ses 800000 € lui servent vraiment
et lui rapporte parce que il est en
liberté conditionnelle et il va
peut-être retourner en prison comment il
a fait person qui jou c'est une somme
qu'il a gagné en jouant avec son
portable dans
sa légalement on peut pas dire ouais
mais il a gagné cet argent alors que il
avait pas le droit d'avoir portable et
ENF y a pas de litige à ce niveau non il
n'a pas le droit d'avoir un téléphone
mais il a gagné la somme j'ai pas vu de
litige absolument
extraordinaire quel moment il est en
cellule et il dit j'ai gagné 800000 il
peut pas se
j'ur non non non non non mais c'est
c'est en sortant il avait de s'approcher
de son excompagne il s'approche quand
même là et donc elle elle dit qu'il l'a
violé et voilà 800 je m' plus 800000 Mo
je juste les chér est-ce que vous avez
déjà gagné une grosse somme vous comme
ça au jeu cyil j'ai gagné 89 € au
loto autant dire que voilà j' dû en
jouer deux fois plus oui au courses moi
au tierc ah je croyais au marché j'ai
gagné deux aubergines plusieurs milliers
d'euros ouais ah ouais oui et alors ils
sont où bah je les ai reperdus après
continu à jouer parce que c'est le piège
vous jouez puis bah oui faut savoir
s'arrêter j'ai pas su ah là là là bon
les ché samedi soir sur TF1 c'était le
deuxème prime de la Star Academy je
tiens à dire quand même que l'équipe de
France va très bien marcher samedi soir
parce que je reçois de nombreux messages
de mes amis de l'équipe de France ça va
très bien marcher vous inquiétez pas
parce que voilà à cause de toi il me
disent ouais va bien marcher tout est de
ma faute tout est de ta faute donc je te
le dis voilà oui vous allez bien marcher
samedi soir vous pouviez arrêter de
m'envoyer des messages d'insulte
voilà ça va pas le faire voilà Nico ça
avait l'air de péter la forme en tout
cas sur la starac il était bien
tellement forme que j'adore il était
comme ça il é en rou libre n
regarde malade vous
l'z c'est St le SAM soir pass une bonne
soirée des petites dans à tout de suite
star mix le Star mix avec vos noms
improbables les gars arrêtez si vous
avez une petite place pour je connais un
chanteur danseur pas mal aussi il est
pas la première pluie he mais mais pour
comprendre la jeunèe de ce projet
inconcevable il y a encore quelques
temps voici quelques images qui nous en
disent un peu plus sur la naissance de
ce groupe déjàéthique oui oui j'ai pété
les PL ok ça
AR qu'est-ce qui se passe je vous
sens voilà ouais TER non mais vous êtes
dur vous arrête moi j'a au moins au
moins il tenteent des choses c'est pas
comme les autres Mo j'aime bien moi
aussi il tente des truc
quas
carrière
aujourd'ui auras sa carrière tu pourras
reparler si j'avais la carrière deic je
Seris ici non mais c'est vrai dans une
carrière BIF toujours en directec
quasiment toujours en
direct pas en direct vendredi pas en
direct samedi non
non lui c'est pas lui qui je peux pas
être en direct Rais bon les chéris vous
avez vu il y a Jennifer qui a oublié les
paroles euh dans le duo voilà samedi
soir vendredi samedi soir je sais pas je
sais pas de qui même pas qui je parle
mais c'est vrai je les aime bien mais je
connais je sais pas qui sont ces gens
regardez non mais franchement regardez
une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fotais à peu près je suis exactement la
femme que j'espérrais
pour toi j'ai
soulevé un amour de
gé chantter allongé après une cascade
c'est difficile comment on fait pour le
souffle par exemple d'A r une petite
phrase
d'ailleurs alors globalement les élèves
ont été bons il y en a un qui s'est
détaché c'est Pierr il a chanté let
James euh cétait considéré comme la
performance de la soirie je sais pas de
qui je parle
[Musique]
regardez
[Applaudissements]
il a été
fantastique parfois il chantait même
mieux que
moi
incroable tout le monde aonnu que Ctait
avec une
Perru c'est bon pas à moi c'est àoun les
gars c'est bon on l'a fait pas j'ai tout
de suite capté le bail voilà donc le
prier éliminé apparemment c'est qui été
sauvé par le public et en fait c'est je
sais pas qui été éliminé en fait c'est
la pauvre Len été éliminé non non non
c'est Louis qui a été éliminé bon voilà
chanté Jennifer c'est il a été sauvé par
ses camarades merci je vois qu'il y a
qui font bien ch merci je vois qu'il y
en a qui font bien ch le samedi soir
merci je voulais que je vous montre un
truc il a une fontaine qui a coûté 1,8
million d'eurosis vous montrer ça en
Autriche regardez et en fait le style
est est très chelou vous vouz montrer ça
mais c'est vrai 1,8 million
regardez cette fontaine
[Musique]
regardez en terme en terme d'information
si vous nous rejoignz à 19h59 ça
s'appelle la
contreprogrammation et c'est vrai que
franchement euh voilà non mais c'est hor
mais combien ça a coûté 1,8 millioneur
cette merde en fait un en fait c'est un
collectif qui a remporté l'appel d'offre
et l'idée était de de montrer la
responsabilité de la société vis-à-vis
de l'eau dont la protection devient de
plus en plus ça saute aux
yeux en tout cas du foutage de gueule
c'est des enfants qui ont fait ça non je
sais pas mais en tout cas c'est
dégueulass ah je vis vous montrer cette
la dinguerie du jour à 2 ans
d'intervalle il y a une habitante des
Hautes Pyrénées elle a rejoué deux fois
la même grille de Kon et elle a gagné
deux fois 800000 € elle a gagné 1,6
million d'euros en 2 ans regardez
regardez la vidéo de la meuf regarde00
elle habite Barbasan desbas 3000
habitants et en août 2021 elle se rend
dans son magasin proxy et décide de
jouer au keno elle remporte le gain avec
l'option gagnant avis c'est-à-dire
qu'elle a 40000 € par an mais toute sa
vie le 2 septembre dernier cette même
joueuse elle rejoue donc ses numéros
fétiches vous l'avez compris et là le
scénario se répète la voilà avec
16600000 € en poche c'est incroyable ce
qui t arriv à cette Fame quand même
ouais pas mal génial ça se trouve c'est
les mêmes numéros tu sais tous les 6
mois un truc de fou si vous gagnez vous
le dites bien sûr frérot pourquoi non
parce que moi je le dis pas par exemple
voà ah oui moi non plus je le dis non
mais je vous donnerai un petit quelque
chose moiuss je gagne merci ah bah bien
sûr si tu gagnes un million 6 tu nous
donnes un petit quelque chose bien sûr
ah bon bah oui combien et quoi par
exemple c'esti pas on va va dîner
ensemble faites pas chier ou
donc là là ça veut dire que vous n'avez
pas encore un million 6 Kelly elle a
plus je les pas d'ailleurs je les pas je
je ne les ai pas mais si je les avais je
don extionnel Quiou bah oui donc vous
nous promettez que quand vous avez un
million 6 sur votre compte vous nous
faites j'ai pas courage on rappelle que
l'insolence considère ça comme de
l'insolence sera pas là demain
sera pas là demain il pas payé hein
payéà pas payé je vis remercier Cyril
Ferro d'avoir été avec
nous et on te retrouve samedi 18 et 25
novemb 100 % logique et dans tout les
rendez-vous sur FR et zéro
faute parce que on on par on va
enchaîner là on on est à l'émission On
continuear merci c mercici t'inquiète